♪ [ Родинонька співає ] ♪
Достатньо, це ж не та пісня,
коли всі водночас співають.
[лунає з телефону] ♪ Ой там на горі. ♪
Галя.
— Алло! Доброго дня.
— Доброго дня, сестро!
Людочко, завтра нам їхати в Сварицевичі,
що в Дубровицькому районі.
Я хочу тебе сьогодні запросити
на репетицію до нашого клубу.
— Всі з торбами. Ви куди?
— На репетицію до вас.
А я думала, що ви в Київ збираєтеся поїхати.
У нашому колективі беруть участь троє моїх сестричок:
Світлана, Людмила, я;
баба Вєрка, Іван Михайлович
і Євгенія Василівна;
ще дві сестри: Лідія і Валя.
І разом з дівчатами попала до нас Наталя.
Нас так швидко почули.
Мабуть, уже в районі немає жодного села,
в якому б не побувала наша славна «Родинонька».
Галя завжди першим голосом тягне,
а ми вже другим.
У нас дуже сильно зливаються голоси.
Ось це і означає слово «рідне».
Дійсно, в нас аж зливаються,
аж бринять голоси.
♪ [Родинонька співає] ♪
Давайте ось так: дві, три пісеньки,
а потім тихенько сядемо і перекусимо,
бо мені важко...
— Скажи, що голодна!
— Голодна!
А можна подумати, що ніби ви вдома були.
Не було коли!
Починаймо!
♪ На музики я збиралася,
У постоли узувалася. ♪
♪ Ой, дьор я гуляла, на бадьор я гуляла,
Із бадьором стояла, на бадьора моргала. ♪
Є!
Позбивалися, але на це і є репетиції.
Щось так склалося,
що в нас немає ні гармоніста, ні бубніста.
Мусиш ти сам тій пісні
трохи кольору додавати.
[жінка свистить]
О, аж кіт злякався!
Це, мабуть, доля навчила співати.
Воно успадкувалося від мами, від тата.
Чула, як мама зі своєю мамою і сестрами
збиралися співати вдома.
Батько сильно любив співати, і дуже гарно
в нього виходило другим голосом.
Мама завжди тягнула високу ноту,
а він баритоном чудово співав.
І ми там з ними все співали, співали,
а потім так подумали:
«А чому б не зробити свій колектив?»
Так і назвали: «Родинонька»
Охх!
Хто там ще йде? Наталя?
Ось там ще одна йде.
— Добрий день!
— Добрий день! Зі святом.
— Дякую, і вас також!
— Дякую.
Все.
Є така справа.
♪ Посіяла огірочки близько над водою, ♪
♪ сама буду поливати дрібною сльозою. ♪
Це все бабусині.
Моя мама співала,
бо від своєї мами навчилася.
І я чула її спів.
Стараємося вишукувати щось таке,
що дуже глибоко є заховане, найстаріше.
Баба Вєрка в нас справжня знахідка.
Вона завжди ось така!
У неї на кожне слово є пісня,
та й куплет буде, точно!
Співала я все життя і тепер співаю.
Люблю.
Часом так хочеться плакати,
що аж цілу пісню переспіваю.
Важке життя було колись.
Тепер я бачу, що молодь живе краще,
але здоров'я в них немає.
Кожен сяде і втупиться в телевізор.
Буде дивитися конкурси, які хоче.
І нащо йти кудись співати?
А хто тут має бути?
— Женя з Іваном.
— А, Женя.
Ах, мої рідні, мої золоті — всі позбиралися!
Ех, мої ж хороші!
Ой, які ви намальовані, а я як мокра курка.
То вже зараз всіх
в село позаганяли,
а то ж усі колись жили на хуторах.
Там співають, там співають,
там співають.
В клуб ходили, ще й ж клуб був.
Раніше світло вимикали в нас.
То сядемо ми удвох в хаті,
бо куди ж іти.
Дві години світла нема,
та й мугикаємо, співаємо.
Як з'являється світло,
тоді знову телевізор дивимося.
Я навчився співати, коли корови пас,
ще в дитинстві.
Навколо корчу ходив і співав.
[сміються]
Діти кажуть:
«Мамо, ну вже ви не можете зупинитися?»
Кажу: «Діти, у вас своя робота, а у нас своя».
Кажу, що як поїду, то мені буде здаватися,
що я з'їхала з глузду.
Душу відвела і все.
Гордієвич, де червона велика сумка?
А, є спереду.
♪ На кого ж ти Ваня та гей Галю покидаєш ♪
♪ Покидаю Галю на людей, на Бога ♪
♪ Зоставайся Галю та гей жива й здорова ♪
Вітаємо вас !
♪ Вітаємо звідусіль і просимо вас, любі гості, ♪
♪ І на тії калачі, що лежали на печі —
просимо вас, любі гості,  ♪
♪ І на тії паляниці, що лежали на полиці,
просимо вас, любі гості! ♪
♪ І на того маціка, що напхались паціка,
просимо вас, любі гості ♪
У всіх тіток повишукували,
повизбирували уже й таке,
що його й страшно прати,
бо там дірки аж розповзаються.
Є таке ще старовинне-старовинне.
Ми, молоді, хочемо
в старий одяг одягнутись,
а баби — в молодіжні костюми, і все!
Хочеться виглядати дуже модно,
а фольклор, вбрання і пісня є древнім і
забутим з бабусиних та прабабусиних скринь.
[співають народні пісні на ходу]
Ой не шкодують долонь, молодці!
Від старого до малого — всі вітають наших артистів.
Ласкаво просимо у наш затишок!
♪ [грає поліська музика] ♪
Я була б щаслива. Дайте мені води!
Там поставте.
♪ [грає поліська музика] ♪
Може, Світлано, ти скажи:
«Вас вітає славна Володимиреччина!
Зі святом, шановний сусіде!»
Вони скажуть, що ми —
колектив «Родинонька».
«Вас вітає колектив "Родинонька"
села Луки...»
А ти...
Фактично «Вас вітає...» знову якось не підходить.
Вас вітає славна Володимиреччина!
Тож, зі святами, шановні сусіди!
Підходьмо ближче!
♪ Ой в саду, садочку травка зелена. ♪
♪ Та дівчина гарна, котра й молода. ♪
Світлана є така більш покладиста,
тому що старша.
Мусить якось вирівнювати це все,
вирішувати різні ситуації.
Галя в нас мов сірник. Раз і горить.
Але як спалахнула, так і швидко загасили ми її.
А я є такою, кажу ж...
Мабуть, на моєму місці мав
би бути хлопець, а виросла я.
Це наша батьківська хата.
Батько дуже рано пішов із життя.
Він навіть не мав 60 років.
Це так мені зараз. Це дуже рано.
Мама трохи довше прожила — 73 роки.
Я вважаю, що це все-таки зарано.
Вони могли б трохи довше прожити.
Коли вони були,
то ти міг їх навіть не помічати.
Але коли батьків не стало,
то їх почало дуже бракувати.
Я би пів життя віддала за те,
щоб вони довше пожили.
Я, коли буває, що плачу — співаю.
Ходжу, співаю і плачу.
Мені так легше витримати це все.
Ось господарство.
Чому ти захрип?
Співав, мабуть, з бабусею вчора
на «водінні куста».
Співав? Трошки співав?
У нас батьки були дуже гостинні.
Якщо людина заходила в їхню хату,
то вони так просто не дозволяли їй піти.
Батьки швидко накривали на стіл і пригощали.
Коли вже випивали чарку,
а потім другу,
то вже хотілося співати.
Колись це було єдиною утіхою на селі.
Давай я тобі покладу трішки.
Так? І ще одненьку.
У мене є кому передати талант.
Ви просто ще не знаєте,
які дівчатка колектив відвідують.
Всі вони шкільного віку,
навчаються у 7, 8 та 9 класі.
«Тітко Галино, навчіть нас співати
чистою українською мовою».
Так ти ж співаєш.
«Ні, я хочу як ви».
Будь ласка!
Пісня — це велика рушійна сила.
Мусите знати,
що вона і зцілює, і крила дає.
♪ Ой сяду я край стола,
Да, гей, ой сяду я край стола, ♪
♪ Повечеряю сама,
Да, гей, повечеряю сама. ♪
♪ Бо милого й нема! ♪